that's not Lawrence and his new  girlfriend the other day what would you  do I say hello got my [ __ ] to go and got  the person you look really happy so you  good because I would activated me on  petty I mean I'd be lying if I said I  didn't bother me a little bit you  together for five years  yeah you ain't been broken up that long  I know but the person he is now is not  the person he was with me  what do you mean like they were out to  lunch and I'm pretty sure he was gonna  pay okay  I've never got that Oh Sherman [ __ ]  don't be paying yeah oh no I got the  [ __ ] with potential no I got the work  in progress and it took a lot of support  and patience and I just I feel like  she's reaping all the benefits of his  time with me yeah  when you said it cuz I know I don't have  a right to feel like that no you have a  right to feel however you want to feel  seriously I don't  you